-Our next guest is a very talented actor
and comedian you know from shows like
"The Mindy Project" and "Happy Endings."
He stars in "Who Invited Charlie?",
which is in theaters and on demand February 3rd.
Let's take a look. -Thank you. Thank you so much.
Listen, I'm making some green smoothies for me and Max.
You want one? -Oh, you know what? No.
I'd actually rather have a big tall glass of warm piss.
I said I'd rather have a tall glass of warm piss!
Did he not hear it?
-Really?
-It's just a little hair of the dog.
You don't have to be so judgy.
-Wait. Where did you even find the mixer for that?
-In your bar.
-Oh, dude, that stuff's like three summers old.
-Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. I guess that's why it's, like, kinda --
It has a fur.
-Please wake back to the show our friend
Adam Pally, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome!
-Thank you so much. So happy to be here.
-This is a very wonderful COVID era film.
You were here right before lockdown.
-Yes. -And then how --
Did you manage to avoid COVID? How did you do?
-No, I've had all the COVIDs.
I got the COVID ones.
The COVID twos.
Then I waited online all night for the COVID threes.
-And you got it? -Snagged 'em.
Snagged 'em. -Early three.
-Yeah, and then my son gave me the COVID fours just as a gift.
[ Laughter ] -Wow.
They're going to, like, test your blood. Special guy.
-Well, I have a little tip. I microdose COVID.
[ Laughter ]
A little bit of COVID every morning,
not too much that you feel the effects,
but enough to build up an immunity.
-Oh, that's great.
-Yeah, it's just -- if you take too much,
you do find yourself at work like,
"I can't breathe or smell."
But that's fine. You know, it's part of it.
-You -- I've enjoyed talking to you
because I'm doing the same.
You've got three New York City kids.
-Yes.
-Been a while since I last checked in.
How has raising them in the city gone?
-You know, it's good.
I enjoy the stigma of New York City kids,
being that they're a little more mature
or they've seen more or gotten to know more.
So I enjoy it.
It is, like, sometimes jarring to me
as someone who also grew up in New York City.
It was a very different New York City.
But, like, my son the other day --
They called from school and they were like,
"Cole, he has a fever. You got to come pick him up."
And I was like, "Oh, my God."
You know, ran to school, got him.
And, you know, he had a fever,
and they're so cuddly when they're sick, you know?
And he was like, "Thanks for picking me up, Dad."
And I was like, "You never have to worry about that, kiddo.
Like, I'm here for you."
And he's like, "I'm a little hungry."
And I was like, "I'll get you whatever -- whatever you want.
We'll get whatever -- whatever you want."
He's like, "For real, Dad?"
And I was like, "Buddy, yes. I'm here for you."
And he's like, "Can we get the baked crab hand roll
from Bond Street?"
[ Laughter ]
-That's not the kind of New York kid you were, huh?
-No.
First of all, I was like, "No.
No. It's like $24.
[ Laughter ]
I didn't mean anything. I meant --"
I was like, "Be reasonable."
-Also, that's not a food when you're sick --
No one's like, "You want a crab roll?"
-Yeah, I was like, "Are you faking?"
I was like, "Come on. You want a baked crab roll?"
But he did. He ate two of them.
And I found myself with an $80 Postmates order
at 2:00 in the afternoon.
You're like, "Jesus. What happened here?"
-You appreciate this --
Or I should say, I appreciate this --
Having three kids, it's hard to keep up with everything.
You do not like when people ask you,
"What are you watching?"
-I don't like that question.
I find it to be, uh, rude.
Because -- And not just because I have three children.
And the truth is, as you know,
you don't get to watch a lot of stuff.
-Yeah. -If I get to watch maybe one,
two shows a year from beginning to end, that's like a lot.
So I feel offended.
And, frankly, maybe it's my age or whatever,
but I feel like a lot of the shows my friends
tell me they're seeing are made up.
[ Laughter ]
It all sounds made up to me.
-Okay. -Like, every show.
And then you ask them who's in it, and it all sounds made up.
It's like someone --
They're like, "What are you watching?"
Like, "Oh, what am I watching?
I don't know. 'Dream Catcher and the Salmon.'
You haven't seen that?
It stars Chris O'Dowd and Patricia Heaton.
It's on Epix.
It's kind of a slow burn. You've got to stick with it."
Like, that sounds like it's a show, but it's not a show.
-Now, you -- Don't take this the wrong way.
You are in a show that seems like one of your made-up shows.
-Yeah, I'm in an action show on Netflix
with Arnold Schwarzenegger. -Okay.
Now, that sounds super made-up.
-It sounds like I'm lying.
Like, it sounds like -- But it's real. That's real!
-And how was your time with Arnold Schwarzenegger?
-Great. -Yeah?
-Yeah. He's amazing. He's like --
I would say, if any-- He's just a great guy.
Like, he -- And everybody around him loves him.
And he's had the same team forever.
And I remember one day I was like,
"Arnold. God. Everybody loves you.
And they've been with you forever, and it's so --
And I kept going. He's like...
[as Schwarzenegger] "Of course. I am the best."
[ Laughter ]
He looked at me like it was like,
"What are you talking about?
You talking about how I could not be the best?
Like, what is -- I'm the best."
I was like, "Oh, right."
Anything. It'd be like, "God, this coffee is so good."
He's like, "Of course it is."
[ Laughter ]
-Did you do -- It's an action thing. Did you do action?
-Yeah, I did a little action. -Okay.
-My first day, I was a little nervous.
We were strapped together in a tandem parachute.
[ Laughter ]
It was nerve-racking, you know.
And, like, he smelled it on me right away.
You know, I'm strapped to him.
And he's like, "This is your first time in a parachute?"
[ Laughter ]
And I was like, "Uh, yeah. Yeah, Arnold."
And he turned to his team and he starts talking in Austrian.
And he's like -- [ Imitating Austrian ]
...first time...
[ Grunts ]
And I'm like --
You know, for a Jew,
you start hearing Austrian, you're like...
[ Laughter ]
You know? So I'm like, "What is --
What is happening?" So I'm like --
And they're all laughing.
You know, everyone's like, "Ha, ha, ha!"
You know? And I was like --
"What's going on? Is everything okay?"
And he's like, "Yeah, yeah."
And I was like, "Well, what did they say
when you said that I was nervous?"
And he's like -- [ Chuckles ]
"They said you're not gonna like it."
[ Laughter ]
Like, that -- That's all they said?
The conversation went on for an hour!
[ Laughter ]
But he's great.
-Yeah. -He's great.
And I really, like -- I would tell everyone, like,
if you get the chance to spend time with him --
He does -- There is a thing that I would love to ask him
because I never...
After I did it, I changed my Waze, you know...
-Yeah, yeah. -...to be Arnold's voice.
-Oh, your Waze. Okay. Gotcha. Your map.
-Yeah. Because you can do that. You can move --
And so after it, this will be fun and, like, remind me.
And so now I have Arnold telling me...
[as Schwarzenegger] "Turn left. I'm not kidding!"
You know? Like, truly.
You put in the destination, and he goes like,
"I'll be back, but first we'll get you
to the Claridge House."
You know? And you're like, "Alright."
But lately I've noticed that his directions --
I don't know if he did this on purpose.
And if he did, he's a genius.
He lau-- He kind of laughs in his direction.
So you don't know if you should believe him.
[ Laughter ]
So he'll be like, "Turn left."
And you'll be like...
[ Laughter ]
Or he'll be like, "Slow down. Speed camera ahead. Ha, ha."
You're like...
[ Laughter ]
Is there a speed camera ahead?
And I feel like he knew that because his voice is so strong
that you're just gonna believe him.
-Yeah. -So I feel like if --
I may be getting pranked
and, like, I'm driving everywhere like --
Both signals are on all the time, and I'm nervous.
-Well, I want to say something that I mean genuinely.
I really hope the show with you and Arnold Schwarzenegger
isn't made up.
I hope it's a real thing. -No. I mean, I filmed it.
So -- It could have been a fever dream. I mean --
It felt insane, but, no, I was there.
-Alright. -I was with him.
-Well, I'm happy you were there.
I am happy you were here.
It's always so great to see you, Adam.
Adam Pally! "Who Invited Charlie?"
is in theaters and on demand February 3rd.
We'll be right back with more "Late Night."